Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux !
Aujourd'hui, on va parler de
3 monstres légendaires :
Celui du Loch Ness qui joue à cache-cache depuis près d'un siècle en Écosse,
le Yéti, un abominable homme des neiges
qui se planque dans l'Himalaya
et le redoutable Kraken
qui sème la terreur dans les océans.
Ces 3 créatures extraordinaires
sont-elles sorties de l'imagination
des Hommes ?
Ou bien y a-t-il un fond de vérité
dans ces histoires ?
Aujourd'hui, on démêle le vrai du faux,
ça va être monstrueux.
Il faudra mettre de l'huile.
Bienvenue dans mon atelier !
Si ce format vous plaît, n'hésitez
pas à liker la vidéo et à vous abonner,
on pourra continuer à se faire peur
avec ces créatures redoutables.
Nous partons d'abord pour l'Écosse,
au sud de la région des Highlands.
C'est ici que se cacherait
le célèbre monstre du Loch Ness,
“Nessie”, pour les intimes.
Il a été photographié en 1934.
Cette année-là, 2 amis se promènent
tranquillement
sur les rives du lac écossais quand, tout à coup,
leur regard est attiré par une étrange créature qui nage en surface.
Ils sont scotchés.
L'animal possède un long cou,
il ressemble à s'y méprendre
à un dinosaure.
Par chance,
l'un des deux hommes est équipé
d'un appareil photo.
Robert Wilson,
c'est son nom, s'empresse donc
d'appuyer sur le déclencheur.
Sa photo, vous l'avez forcément
déjà vue dans les livres.
Elle est aussitôt publiée
dans le "Daily Mail",
un journal britannique très populaire,
et le cliché
fait aussitôt le tour de la planète.
Chose inattendue, du jour au lendemain, le monde entier se presse
sur les rives du Loch Ness avec l'espoir
d'apercevoir la créature.
Autant vous dire que pour les hôteliers
du coin, c'est une aubaine.
Jusque-là, les touristes ne se bousculaient pas sur les bords du Loch Ness,
pourtant, ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'une bête à l'allure préhistorique
est signalée dans le lac.
En 1933,
un couple avait déjà prétendu avoir aperçu
un énorme animal
rouler à la surface et plonger.
1933, un an avant la photo.
Les premières traces de cette créature
remonteraient même à l'an 565.
Un missionnaire irlandais,
visitant la région, témoigne
avoir surpris un monstre
rugissant en train d'attaquer un homme.
Il l'aurait ensuite sauvé en faisant fuir
la créature avec un signe de croix.
Alors, mythe ou réalité ?
À l'époque, les scientifiques, intrigués,
se penchent sur la question
car il pourrait s'agir d'un plésiosaure,
un animal aquatique qui a vécu au Crétacé.
Aurait-il miraculeusement survécu à l'extinction des dinosaures,
il y a 65 millions d'années ?
Cette hypothèse est séduisante
mais elle est loin de faire l'unanimité.
À cause du cou de Nessie.
D'après la photo, celui-ci est courbé,
or, le plésiosaure possédait un cou droit
et rigide.
De plus, c'était un animal marin
qui n'aurait pas survécu dans les eaux douces du Loch Ness.
Ces arguments scientifiques
sont imparables et pourtant,
ils ne parviennent pas à convaincre ceux
qui croient à l'existence de la créature.
Pour eux,
Nessie n'est peut être pas un plésiosaure,
il pourrait parfaitement appartenir
à une autre espèce préhistorique.
De nombreuses expéditions
sont alors organisées sur le lac
dans le but de dénicher des indices.
Durant plusieurs décennies,
le Loch Ness est fouillé, sondé
centimètre carré par centimètre carré mais, en vain,
pas la moindre trace de Nessie.
Et si toute cette histoire n'était qu'un
canular ?
La photo, un montage ?
La réponse à cette question
sera obtenue en 1993.
Cette année-là, Christian Spurling,
le compère du photographe,
révèle enfin que le monstre de la photo
était un vulgaire
morceau de carton découpé et fixé sur un sous-marin d'enfant.
C'était une grosse blague
et tout le monde a plongé.
Fin de l'histoire ?
Eh bien, détrompez-vous.
Le célèbre lac écossais attire toujours
autant les touristes et les scientifiques.
En juin 2018, une équipe néo-zélandaise
n'a pas hésité à mener
une étude sur 250 échantillons collectés
dans les eaux du Loch Ness.
Des centaines de millions de séquences ADN ont été analysées
et comparées
avec de nombreuses bases de données.
Les résultats ont conduit
les scientifiques à écarter
définitivement l'hypothèse
d'un reptile venu du fin fond du Crétacé.
En revanche, le lac regorgerait
bien de poissons à long cou
mais il s'agit de simples anguilles.
Quittons maintenant les brumes de l'Écosse
pour nous rendre
sur les pentes de l'Himalaya.
C'est ici, à la frontière
du Tibet, de l'Inde et du Népal
que se cacherait
l'abominable homme des neiges.
Un être effrayant
de plus de 2 mètres de hauteur,
recouvert de longs poils et affublé
d'une énorme tête.
La possibilité de son existence
est révélée en 1951
par Eric Shipton, un explorateur britannique qui tente de gravir l'Everest.
Durant le trajet,
il fait une étrange découverte,
il s'agit d'une empreinte de pied géante.
Interloqué par sa taille et par sa forme
il la prend en photo et poursuit sa route.
Une fois rentré en Angleterre,
l'explorateur propose son cliché à différents magazines
qui le publient aussitôt.
La photo fait sensation.
Cette empreinte de pied
ne ressemble à rien de connu
et les scientifiques qui se penchent
dessus se posent des questions.
L'empreinte
ressemble à celle d'un hominoïde,
la famille qui comprend les êtres humains
et les grands singes.
Mais elle est bien trop grande
pour être celle d'un homme
et aucun des grands singes connus
ne pourrait survivre
dans cette région du monde.
S'agirait-il alors d'une supercherie ?
Impossible.
Eric Shipton est un explorateur
qui jouit d'une excellente réputation.
Jamais, il n'aurait osé faire une chose
pareille.
Certains avancent
alors que ce pied pourrait appartenir
à une créature mi-homme, mi-singe,
très présente dans les légendes locales
du Tibet et du Népal : Le Yéti.
“Yéti”, dans la langue locale
signifie “homme sauvage”.
En France, on lui trouve un autre nom : l'abominable homme des neiges.
À partir des années 50,
le monde occidental se passionne
pour cette créature que l'on décrit comme un dangereux mangeur d'Hommes.
Hergé, le célèbre créateur de Tintin,
profite de cet engouement pour en faire
un personnage de premier plan
dans “Les aventures de Tintin au Tibet”.
Le Yéti prend la forme d'une
bête effrayante mais dotée d'un cœur d'or.
En attendant,
les années passent et les scientifiques
sont dans l'incapacité
de mettre un nom sur la créature qui
a laissé cette empreinte dans la neige.
Si bien qu'en 2012, Brian Sykes,
un généticien britannique
qui n'a pas froid aux yeux,
lance une vaste étude consacrée à l'abominable homme des neiges.
Il ne s'intéresse pas à la photo
mais à des poils d'animaux
non identifiés,
récoltés sur les pentes de l'Himalaya.
Le scientifique collecte 57 échantillons
et compare leur ADN à celui d'un ancêtre
de l'ours polaire qui a vécu en Norvège
il y a, entre, 120 000 et 40 000 ans.
Ses conclusions sont formelles,
55 échantillons appartiennent
à des animaux bien connus :
cheval, vache, loup, raton laveur et même porc-épic.
Mais les 2 derniers ont une correspondance avec cet ours disparu.
Surprise ! Le Yéti pourrait être
un croisement entre un ours brun
et un ours polaire disparu
il y a des milliers d'années.
Un mystère chasse l'autre.
Si vous avez tremblé devant Pirates
des Caraïbes au cinéma,
vous allez trembler devant notre dernière
créature légendaire :
le Kraken.
Le capitaine du bateau fantôme, “le
Hollandais volant”,
se sert de ce calamar géant aux multiples tentacules
pour anéantir les navires ennemis.
Jack Sparrow, alias Johnny Depp,
mène un terrible combat contre lui
dans le deuxième volet de la saga.
Le Kraken fait couler les navires
mais il fait aussi couler
beaucoup d'encre depuis le Moyen Âge.
La description qu'en donnent les auteurs
scandinaves de l'époque
ne donne pas envie de le rencontrer.
Je les cite : “C'est un monstre qui sème la terreur dans les mers
qui séparent la Norvège et l'Islande.
Il est capable d'avaler des Hommes,
des bateaux et des baleines.
Le Kraken mesure
des dizaines de mètres d'envergure
et pourrait atteindre la taille d'une
petite île."
La créature doit son nom au mot norvégien “krake”
qui signifie “animal malsain”.
Tout un programme.
Du coup, ce redoutable calamar est-il
sorti de l'imagination des marins,
Ou bien, y a t-il un fond de vérité
dans cette histoire ?
De nombreux témoignages récoltés par le passé semblent confirmer son existence.
Le plus célèbre remonte à 1861,
il émane d'un marin français,
le capitaine de frégate, Frédéric Bouyer.
Celui-ci affirme qu'au nord-est de Tenerife, en plein océan Atlantique,
son navire s'est trouvé nez à nez avec le fameux Kraken.
Selon ses dires,
la rencontre a été houleuse,
ses hommes se sont vus contraints
de sortir les harpons et les fusils
pour ne pas finir entre ses tentacules.
Frédéric Bouyer relate
cette rencontre dans un rapport
qu'il soumet à la très sérieuse Académie des Sciences.
Il a également conservé
un morceau du Kraken
qu'il a fait parvenir à un biologiste
mais celui-ci est incapable
de déterminer
la nature exacte de cet animal.
L'affaire fait beaucoup de bruit,
si bien que des années plus tard,
Jules Verne s'en inspire pour son roman d'aventures “20 000 lieues sous les mers”.
Il contribue ainsi à populariser
le mythe du Kraken dans le monde entier.
La plupart des scientifiques en sont sûrs,
cette créature existe bel et bien.
Il s'agit du fameux calamar géant.
Sa taille a sans doute été exagérée
par les navigateurs et les pêcheurs
mais il pourrait quand même atteindre
13 mètres d'envergure.
On sait peu de choses sur lui
car il vit dans les grandes profondeurs.
Il est donc particulièrement difficile
de l'observer et d'analyser son comportement.
Mais en 2012, une équipe scientifique
japonaise a pu filmer
pour la première fois
un calamar géant par 900 mètres de fond
dans l'océan Pacifique.
La longueur de l'animal est estimée à 8 mètres.
Depuis, personne n'a
jamais recroisé le terrible Kraken, vivant.
Le dernier spécimen connu
a été retrouvé en 2022
sur une plage de Nouvelle-Zélande mais
il était mort et partiellement dévoré.
Je suis curieux de savoir
lequel de ces 3 monstres
vous avez préféré
ou lequel vous a fait le plus peur.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu alors
n'hésitez pas à liker et à vous abonner.
Puis, si vous aimez ce genre
d'histoires, signalez-le
moi également en commentaire,
j'en ai plein les tiroirs.
À très bientôt,
chers Épicurieuses et Épicurieux.